c'était lola et jérémy nom et par un
journal intime vidéo du coran bons
souvenirs des plus belles choses de leur
vie à jemappes une lola j'adore les
super héros ou la méga regardez-moi ça
petit paquet
ya pas une seule raison sur terre qui
justifie ce que tu m'as fait j'ai merdé
qu'est ce que vous allez faire j'ai
trouvé le truc pour récupérer l'eau la
voile à elle son truc
les héros de bande dessinée ont créé un
gang de super héros superman
pourquoi jacques aux choses sérieuses
ont fait faux kidnapping de stars et la
rançon c'est lola barreau qui naquit
monsieur 4 chez vous le soir
gong mais merde j'ai croisé l'eau l'air
et le toit qu'un mec genre beau gosse et
make way beau gosse j'avoue et si tu
étais un pote connor island il était
vraiment pas beau très très moche très
moche même trop con tout ça en vaut 14
le planteur ou pas les croire en fait si
j'ai pas de mec là dans mon coeur c'est
justement parce que tu vois j'ai envie
d'être tranquille dit avoir une grande
courge la colère que tu aimes toi mais
si je n'aime comme un faux-pas pas
justement alors juste à temps là bas va
la récupérer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle veut du grand moulin du magic
[Musique]
tu sois moi je sois heureux
quand je t'ai vu avec moi je me suis dis
pas ça dit elle va être bouleversée
analyse
[Musique]